werden wir bald zu alien bleiben wir
haben noch nicht einmal annähernd
geschafft unser sonnensystem zu
erforschen aber jetzt wird vom die reise
zu unserem nächsten stern geplant es
immerhin und viel licht herein lang also
mit lichtgeschwindigkeit in vier jahren
zu erreichen was ja leider nicht möglich
ist auf dem soll die reise dorthin nur
20 jahre dauern
wie das gehen soll jetzt winken zum
zweiten fiction unter den namen break
star schott neuen winzige raumschiffe
zur erkundung strecken ins all geschickt
werden
die raumschiffe werden auf einem nur mit
dem nötigsten ausgestattet war eine
kleine wenige millimeter dicke platine
und einem sonnensegel bestehen mit dem
song wege spart man sich jegliche große
antriebstechnologie raumschiffe mit
sonnen wegen können von der erde aus mit
dem nötigen schub versorgt werden
mehrere leser werden auch die
raumschiffe gerichtet um wie in
minutenschnelle auf 20 prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit zu beschleunigen
durch die leichtbauweise können die
raumschiffe strecken für die andere
gerätschaften satelliten oder ähnliches
mehrere monate gebraucht haben in
wenigen tagen oder sogar stunden
zurücklegen
eines der hauptziele dass im zuge des
wechsels war schott projektes erreicht
werden soll ist das sternensystem alpha
centauri 4,37 lichtjahre von unserer
erde entfernt gott ist erst im letzten
jahr ein erdähnliche planet entdeckt
worden auf dem leben geben könnte
proxima zb eine reise dorthin wurde mit
herkömmlichen raumschiffen rund 30 bis
40 tausend jahre dauern
die breakthrough star schiffe würden das
system in 20 jahren erreichen begleitet
wird das projekt von stephen hawking
mark zuckerberg von facebook juri milner
und dem ehemaligen chef des ames
research centers der nager bieter worden
es könnte einen gewaltigen sprung in der
wissenschaft bedeuten nur könnte
forscher des max-planck-instituts für
sonnensystemforschung haben sich dem
projekt gewidmet und die antwort auf
eine der wichtigsten
agentur aufgabe gemacht wie könnte man
bei einer deutschen beziehung die
wissenschaftliche ausbeute optimieren da
die raumschiffe waren sich schnell durch
das universum schießen werden bleibt
kaum zeit für umfangreiche messungen
genauer gesagt wird es nur wenige
sekunden ganz in die raumschiffe schon
wieder vorbei geflogen oder es gibt noch
eine andere möglichkeit
michael witte und rené heller haben
einen weg gefunden die flugbahn zu
optimieren dafür gingen sie tat von
einer raumsonde aus die insgesamt
weniger als 100 gramm wiegt und mit
einem 100.000 quadratmeter großen eklat
ausgestattet ist das entspricht der
fläche von 14 fußballfeldern
mit der annäherung an alpha centauri
wächst die bremskraft die stärker die
bremsung ist desto mehr geschwindigkeit
kann bei der ankunft abgebaut werden und
desto schneller darf die sonde bei ihrem
start im sonnen griffin sein
gleichzeitig fehlt der stern die sonde
mit seiner schwerkraft dieser effekt
nicht für sich nutzen um sie auf ihrer
bahn abzulenken solche frieden bei
manöver haben raumsonden in unserem
sonnensystem vielfach ausgeführt nun
könnte sich das läge so ausrichten dass
der strahlungsdruck von stern die sonne
so stark abbremst und ablenkt dass diese
schon nach wenigen tagen alpha centauri
b erreicht und dort nochmals abgebremst
in richtung von proxima centauri
geschleudert wird so zumindest wird das
vorhaben der beiden beschrieben
neben dem ausgefeilten flugmanöver gibt
es noch andere stellschrauben an denen
gedreht werden könnte den leser könne
man beispielsweise durch die natürliche
strahlung der sonne ersetzen und so
weiter es wird also immer realistischer
dass eine deutsche reise wirklich
stattfinden kann und vielleicht
entdecken dann auch zum ersten mal leben
auf einem fremden planeten allerdings
würde die reise sagen rund 100 jahre
dauern
das bremsmanöver schrift ziemlich viel
zeit mehr zum break star schaut projekt
erfahrt ihr im video hier
und wenn euch dieses video also drauf
klicken auf jeden fall wenn ich dieses
video hier gefallen hat dann hat und
gerne genau dafür einen daumen nach oben
und ein kostenloses abo klicken und
nicht den blick auf die glocke vergessen
und was man ihr werden wir dort
außerirdisches leben entdecken die nasa
sagt ja dabei
nächsten 20 jahren so weit sein wird
also dafür hinweg naja dafür kommt
morgen ja schon das nächste krieg zum
video also bis dann bleibt